ونعود الى مراسلنا عبد الباقي الظافر من
الخرطوم الذي كان قبل قليل يحدثنا عن
مشاهداته ووعائد من المناطق الساخنه التي
شهدت وتشهدت مواجهات واشتباكات عبد الباقي
نعم حسن
كان بالنسبه لنا يوم صعب انا كنت في مسرح
الاحداث كما قلت في مداخل السابقه على بعد
200 متر من مغر اقامه الدعم السريع و500
متر من مقر اقامه رئيس مجلس السياده
القائد العام ومنذ الوهله الاولى
حدثت اشتباكات استخدام لمختلف الاسلحه بعد
نحو ساعتين تم قطع التيار الكهربائي من
المنطقه وهي منطقه حساسه وكانت دائما
كهربائي مستقر ولم نعرف ما هي الاسباب حتى
لحظه
كان هنالك
اطلاق نار ومن مختلف الاتيحات ملاحظات
الاولى عندما خرجت لم اشاهد تاثر منزل
قائد الدعم السريع بالقصف بشكل ظاهري
وايضا كان ذلك قبل ساعه ونص خرجنا الشارع
المطار ولاحظتها ان الاستكازات ونقاط
التفتيش الموجوده داخل حي المطار يسيطر
عليها الدعم السريع وكذلك ثلاثه من
الارتكازات اثنين في شارع المطار والثالث
في منطقه الخرطوم اثنين ايضا يسيطر عليها
قوات الدعم السريع ووصلنا الان الى بعدها
الى نقطه امنه تمكنتها من الحديث معكم
ايضا وصلتنا استغاثه من مدرسه كمبوني وسوف
الخرطوم وقالوا ان هنالك نحو 250 طالب
وطالبه لظروف انسانيه حرجه وكذلك تمت
الاستخاثه من سكان حي المطار في جبهه مروي
مصادر العسكريه ان هنالك نحو 40 عربه
لا تضافيه للقوات الدعم السريع وقالت لنا
مسار انهم يتوقعون
الدعم السريع بحسب ذاتي المصادر ومصادر
المحليه
عبد الباقي
يعني
اشرت الى نقطه جدا مهمه ولها علاقه بمن
يسيطر على طريق المطار وبعض المناطق وتقول
الدعم السريع هو الذي يسيطر عليها
لكن ايضا
هناك معلومات
ترد على شاشتنا حول تحرك سلاح الجو
السوداني وقصفه
لمعسكر قوات الدعم السريع في ضاحيه صالحه
بي ام درمان هل لديك معلومات حول ذلك
نعم قالت لنا مصادر انهم الان يتعاملون مع
معسكر صالحه وقال المصادر انهم يتجنبون
التعامل مع مواقع الدعم السريع داخل
المناطق الماهوله جدا لسكان عن طريق
استخدام سلاح الطيران باعتبار ان السلاح
الطيران يمكن ان يوقف خسائر وسط المدنيين
لذلك هم لا يحبون استخدامها
في منطقه الصالحه
الخرطوم وتبدو بعيده نسبيا عن وسط الخرطه
عبد الباقي فقط في نقطه في نقطه اخيره
لانه انتهى وقتنا لكن هل لك ان تلخص لنا
بحسب مشاهداتك المناطق التي يسيطر عليها
الدعم السريع داخل العاصمه
هذه المشاهدات ايضا عمرها نحن بساعه ونصف
من زمان وهي يعني فتره طويله في العمل
العمليات العسكريه مشاهداتي ان المنطقه
حول حي المطار كانت تسيطر على قوات الدعم
السريع وايضا في بدايه الشارع المطار من
الناحيه الشماليه الى الخرطوم اثنين تسيطر
عليها قوات الدعم السريع وهي قوات وتم
ايقاف عربتنا اكثر من مره وتفتيشها ثم
سماح لنا بالمرور اذا
نشدد على النقطه التي ذكرها عبد الباقي
الظافر ان هذه المناطق التي اشار اليها هي
تحت سيطره الدعم السريع لكن من قبل ساعه
ونصف او ساعتين
وبالتالي الامور مرشحه للتغير
دقيقه بدقيقه وساعه بساعه شكرا لك عبد
الباقي الظافر حدث حدثتنا من الخرطوم